- Then I feel something
tickle my anus.
It felt like a feather.
I turn around.
There's no one there.
So now I think something
paranormal is happening.
Like it's Liberace's ghost
going, "Hi."
[grunts]
[dark electronic music]
♪
[grunting]
[cheers and applause]
- Ladies and gentlemen,
he's got his own podcast
called TigerBelly.
Please give it up
for the hilarious comic
Mr. Bobby Lee, everybody.
Let him hear it.
♪
So this story happened 15 years
ago.
It involves sexualities,
and it's unholy,
and 15 years ago, I just want
to let you guys know
that I just couldn't get laid.
I'm shaped
like a human dumpling.
I look like Pikachu
with diabetes.
I don't look good.
I don't even know
how to fuck.
This is what I do,
like a Hula-Hoop.
This is how I fuck.
So 15 years ago,
I got a gig in Las Vegas,
my first headlining gig
at the Riviera,
and they were gonna pay me $150.
Thank you.
One show.
And--I'm making it.
And they wouldn't fly me out,
so I had these two comics
drive me to Las Vegas,
Bryan [bleep].
He's a real guy.
And Aaron [bleep],
and we drive to Las Vegas,
and we're on
Las Vegas Boulevard.
We're at a stoplight,
and we're in Bryan's Bronco.
And a truck pulls up next to us,
a blue truck, with two
of the ugliest white girls
I've ever seen
in my fuckin' life.
They were twins.
They had mullets.
They had Confederate flag
T-shirts on.
They had acid-washed jeans.
I'm getting hard right now.
[laughter]
And they yell into the car,
"We think you're cute."
They weren't talking about me.
They weren't talking
about Bryan, 'cause Bryan
is the ugliest white dude
I've ever seen.
If you know Bryan [bleep],
he has no jawline
or fuckin' chin.
His neck just blends
into his face.
He looks like a tiki statue
or Beaker from "The Muppets."
He looks awful.
He has a Gollum body.
You know how white guys
have skinny arms and a belly?
God damn, he's unfuckable.
Anyway, guys, the reason why
I just said that--
I called them out,
because I asked them
to do this story with me,
and he says, "No, I have kids."
Fuck you, Bryan.
That's what you get.
They were talking about Aaron,
and Aaron jumped out
of the Bronco.
He goes
into the truck, and they just
drive into the distance,
you know what I mean?
We're like,
"Hope you don't die," you know?
So we go to the Riviera,
and it's, like, 9:00 p.m.,
and I tell Bryan, I go, "Bryan,
I need to write a set list,
"so you just do your own thing.
I'll see you at the show.
It's at midnight."
So I go do my set list.
At midnight, I show up
at the Riviera,
and Aaron and Bryan rolls up
with these two girls,
and Aaron pulls me aside,
and he says, "Hey, dude,
if you're funny,
they'll fuck you."
And I got, "Nah."
Then Aaron goes, "Hey, 'cause
they're white supremacists."
I swear to fucking God.
So then, "Yes, I'll do it then."
Because if you're ethnic and you
fuck two white supremacists,
that's a win for my people.
[laughter]
They're gonna build a statue of
me in Seoul.
So I go up,
and I do the show,
and I'm pretty good,
you know what I mean?
I'm likeable.
Focus groups like me.
I test well.
And after the show,
we go up to the room,
and it's debauchery.
I mean, the air is thick.
It's like a Cambodian jungle.
You can slice the air
with a machete,
you know what I mean?
And we were all wearing condoms.
[laughs]
So it's two hours
of just sexualities, and...
I get the skinny one.
We switch off.
So...
[giggling]
eventually, I have the fat one
on the bed, right?
One of 'em was fat, by the way.
I'm doing doggie style,
and Aaron has the other one
in the other bed,
and I look around.
"Where the fuck's Bryan?"
Nobody knows where Bryan is.
He disappeared.
The bathroom light is off,
right?
So he's not in there.
So I go, "Fuck him."
I keep going, right?
Then I feel something...
tickle my anus.
It felt like a feather.
I turn around.
There's no one there.
So now I think something
paranormal is happening.
Like it's Liberace's ghost
going,
"Hi," or whatever.
So I keep going, right?
Then I definitely
feel something
rubbing against my anus, right?
Bryan had crawled
underneath my body,
underneath her body,
and started eating her out
while I was fucking her,
which makes him a warrior.
He's a fucking soldier, guys.
I gave him a Purple Heart
afterwards, seriously.
And I go, "Get the fuck out
of there."
He goes, "She likes it.
She likes it."
So all right.
I keep going.
I start power fucking her.
You know how you do it?
You power fuck?
You speak English?
He said, "I don't know power
fuck."
I go rapid, ka-ka-ka,
you know what I mean?
And my penis slips out,
and it goes right into
Bryan's eye.
[laughter]
I've never heard a scream
that loud before.
[screams]
You know, it is fucking crazy.
And then we stopped immediately.
Putting a penis in an eye
is a party-stopper.
I don't care where you are,
right?
It just ruins the mood.
You can get a gold medal at the
Olympics
as they're putting the fucking
ribbon around your neck,
and a P goes in your eye,
it's done, okay?
So anyway, we get up,
and I take him to breakfast.
[laughing]
I do,
'cause I'm a good person,
you know what I mean?
So we're at breakfast,
and we're eating bacon or
whatever.
and I look across,
and Bryan's eye
is completely closed
with a yellow film around it.
crowd: Ooh.
- I know.
And I go, "Dude, your eye."
He goes, "I think we should go
to the hospital.
It burns."
I go, "Nah.
Put some Clorox on it
or whatever."
I wanted him to lose the eye
just for the story.
I blinded a man
with my penis once.
So we get in the car.
It's 6:00 in the morning.
I'm fuckin' tired.
You speak English?
You all right? All right...
we drive to the hospital,
and I don't know what to say.
I've never told a doctor
that I poked somebody in the eye
with my penis before.
Do you lie?
What the fuck do you do?
So Bryan goes, "I got it."
So we're sitting there
in the emergency room.
Doctor walks in.
He says, "What happened?"
Bryan points at me.
He says, "He skull-fucked me."
[laughter]
That was the story.
Thank you.
[dark electronic music]
♪